one thing that i've never understood
right
okay i use smart watch right i got small
wash right yeah i hate i i think that
apple watches look like toys i don't
understand why people wear them like to
be fair i think they look kind of ugly
as well they look they look like a toy
they look like something that like ben
10 would wear yeah except less cool it
looks like something i'd raise like
pokemon on you know like i mean everyone
wears them yeah but like i like the
stuff
i don't like
square watches i like the smartwatches
that look like watches because then you
don't look like you're like you're about
to go to silicon valley and sell stock
you know what i mean like yeah i don't
know do you like do you look at the
apple watches or are you interested i
mean i i'm very indifferent i don't wear
watches i don't wear smart watches i
wear i wear smartwatch but just because
i like the buzz it just buzzes i don't
look at it i just want to know
because i put my phone on silent see i
don't like that because i get like i get
bombarded with enough notifications on
my phone that sometimes i just need to
like put my phone aside and be like okay
there's a separation but to me if i wear
a smart watch then i'm constantly like
getting bombarded with notifications and
you know that's why that's why i stopped
wearing a small watch i just wear the
jojo yeah just because like again like i
want to wear my jersey watching i also
don't want to ruin it i mean yeah i'm
scared to like ruin it value yeah
i guess but but it's like i don't know i
i hated i liked the smart watch at first
because i was like oh cool i can [ __ ]
see everything without opening my phone
this is great maybe it'll stop me from
getting on my phone yeah it didn't
well actually it just prolonged the
process of me actually pulling out my
phone it's just yeah but i don't know
for me personally it's helped where
i don't always wanna
99 of texts i don't reply to immediately
mm-hmm and i want to find out do i need
to reply to this so when i feel a buzz
i'll just check all right not important
all right yeah i don't i'm not getting
my phone out i'm just going to carry on
yeah that's kind of what i do you know
for me because because we do get
bombarded with a lot of notifications
emails like twitter whatever but i just
want to like
when i'm trying to be productive i want
to just like get all this done in one
point like i want to reply to all my
messages within one point look at all my
notifications at one point and then just
leave it aside
but like i feel for me if i had that
constant buzz on my [ __ ] wrist i just
wouldn't be able to concentrate because
i'd be like is this
you think so at first yes
you do but then after time it's like
anything you just kind of become numb to
it and sometimes i've i've been buzzed a
bunch and i don't even realize it but
doesn't that completely defeat the
purpose yeah
i think i need a bit like building a
taser or something
[Applause]
he
yeah i think so like
yeah i don't know and also honestly i
kind of like how it looks i don't know i
like this that is a nice watch yeah
right like it's one of the ones that
looks decent so i i yeah something about
the
it being square
makes it because the watch in your mind
is like ingrained as a circular shape
watch is circle circular right yeah so
like
when i see a square i don't know what it
is about my brain that just thinks oh
that's just a construct of your mind
it's not just a pc case that costs a
brand it's a cheese grater but just just
just just wait circular monitors
the future is now think about it yeah
yeah
we make our watches square and our
monitor
that's the exact reason why i don't have
a [ __ ] i i i watch either is it all
nice well now but you wear a square
watch what do you like about the square
watch
the squirt
nice he likes squares like it's like a
spongebob on your hand yeah
what you're saying yeah not as strongly
as you know i feel so strongly about
that i mean for me like tech has always
just been
application and functionality like i've
i've i've never really cared too much
about
having the newest tech as long as i get
something that gets me my work done or
gets me something gets gets me that gets
me the functionality that i need and i
guess that's just like
that's just like my engineering mind
like i don't care i don't care how it
works i just care that it gets the
[ __ ] job done yeah it's just me
maxing his life you know i think that's
why this new phone's annoyed me so much
is that
in like a in like a from specification
level it's amazing and it's got some
really cool features but the one thing
that it pisses me off is that just
sometimes little things are being
annoying on this yeah the generation
that's what pisses me do you know the
biggest thing that pisses me off about
this phone it's such a minor thing
what's the phone by the way uh it's a
samsung
s
21 okay okay yeah s21 um so what do you
think the power button is
oh is it below the volume
no so the power button
is you have to press these two buttons
at the same time oh
it used to be it used to be this button
what's this button it's the bixby button
and uh if
it's bixby is like meant to be like the
samsung equivalent to like siri but i
don't know a single [ __ ] person who's
ever used bixby no one likes in my life
i've just heard about bixby about five
seconds ago
no what the [ __ ] is bixby no one but
samsung puts it in everything rugrats
character
it is yeah it is it's it's like meeting
someone who uses bing you know like like
who who are these people who who are
these people using ash jeeves
this is what i love android right but
this is what they've been pissing me off
with lately every time they add
something they take away something or
change it a lot right so i remember on
my old phone used to be able to
screenshot the whole page so it would
scroll down and then for some reason one
day they just removed it they didn't say
why why would you remove that and then
not add anything to like replace it and
now they've added it back in with the
new one but for like two years i lost
the ability to screenshot the whole page
that's right that's the selling point
right right you're being sold on a new
functionality it's a classic apple a
classic apple and then
and then i remember when you wanted the
screenshot it was used to be simple you
i couldn't you just press the power
button down and then it would like oh no
no you could press like a combo and you
could screenshot and then they change it
like hold the power button down and then
you press it to screenshot something
like that i can't remember exactly but
like they just change [ __ ] for no
[ __ ] apparent reason and then they
call it new and i'm like [ __ ] off
it's not new if you just made [ __ ] more
complicated for me [ __ ] off and yet he
somehow still is part of the system wow
you're part of the cycle you're you are
trapped you are trapped it's trapped in
the tech side
they've made you angry and you can't get
out i just like android too much you
know and i don't really have anything to
to go because i think a lot of the time
with apple
the reason why people are quite loyal
and you know i understand this is that
they buy a lot of apple products yeah
they have to uh well that's why you
bought the pixel right because you're
part of the google
yeah yeah but that's because like team
google android works well with windows
and you know stuff like that it all kind
of works well with each other you know
and emulation is easier on android and
all that except isn't it weird that the
pixel doesn't work with the chromecast
now it doesn't but chromecast is
google's thing yeah so i don't know so
you think the one phone that would work
with something google related would be
the google phone whatever this is yeah
why did they remove the functionality
yeah because i can i can control it i
can control it with the i control them
yeah so now what i have to do and i want
to control that instead of getting the
volume i have to go to google home app
scroll down oh my god scroll down yes
yeah i know scroll down to the to the
the device i have three devices in my
home as well so i have to click it and
then i have to go on the volume slider
and do it it's [ __ ] stupid i don't
know why google did this [ __ ] like it's
like they [ __ ] hate me you know
they're already paying my bills with
youtube like why are you making me sound
for google i'm already trapped so what
does the volume button do
nothing normal volume so it's your phone
volume yeah but normally when you'd
chromecast things it would it you'd be
able to choose all of the volumes yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah like sometimes i can
still do that on my samsung yeah because
sometimes i'll
for whatever reason if i'm feeling like
a psychopath i'll play a video through
my phone cast a video and then maybe
i'll be on call and i can control all
the three volumes separately yeah i do
that sometimes
welcome to an influencer's life
we've become that meme of just like the
guy who has like four screens looking at
like the stock market or something
instead of talking four different videos
it's just memes
you need to like consume all the memes
at the same time i did something one
time and i was like what the [ __ ]
wrong with me i was just watching two
videos and both volumes were playing and
then i realized 30 seconds into doing it
i was like yeah i can't hear i can't
hear it yeah just listening to both at
the same time and trying to take them
both in like don't know why yeah there's
no apparently you're like challenging
yourself no i wasn't doing it
consciously i just did it by accident
and i just didn't stop it i was just
letting them both play and i was like
this is good need some more sleep i i
have an issue of uh opening too many
tabs and sometimes yeah i've seen some
some sometimes sometimes one of the tabs
is playing volume and it's like [ __ ]
trying to find where's wally in in the
[ __ ] tab section it's just like which
one of these is playing [ __ ] music
right how many tabs on average do you
have open okay okay okay okay i'm not a
psychopath i've seen like i've seen some
people who have like a hundred or like
you know how can the browser even run at
that point okay i've seen tabs when it's
just like it gets like 20 tabs and then
you have to like click an expansion to
get like the next 20 times that's just
like a [ __ ] yeah when it gets like 50
tabs it condenses it down into one drop
down yeah yeah yeah it's like 30.
yeah it's like 30. too many too many
yeah so what what i do is if it's like
10 tabs and i you know in case i don't
want to close one of the tabs i just
open another window and uh start start
and i stack them on top of each other
now how much ram is that using i don't
know
how much ram do you have
it's funny because when i'm editing uh
when i'm editing like even like
heavy like intensive videos right i look
at i look at the ram usage and google
chrome is like still more than my
editing software a lot of them close
your [ __ ] browsers gone
what if i need it what if i need it just
in case
there's a thing called history
that saves it all yeah obviously you do
not know how many memes i have to go
through like like
maybe you should just view your memes in
like incognito or something that works
like not important because like what
what if i have to have like if i have
like one important research topic that
i'm looking for that i need to use
research
for like a video or something [ __ ] me
i have the one tab that is the important
research topic that i'm working on for a
video and then i have like 30 meme tabs
and finding that one research tab is
[ __ ] impossible
what if you just separate the research
into a different window
because because with the length that
memes last i'm always constantly looking
up i feel like you have
some kind of issues here
just you know putting them into
categories and actually i don't know
organizing your [ __ ] tab scan
probably probably probably that would
help me yeah that would help i literally
try to have as little tabs open as
possible because i just don't want tabs
open if i have more than five i start
closing ones that i don't need yeah yeah
five is like the limit five is the limit
five is like five is basic five
i'll have twitter open emails
youtube and that's it really if i if i
have to have more than five tabs open
i'm opening another window
yeah
i'm just putting on another one so you
gotta tab for youtube twitter emails
um
something for music maybe or like a
video to play in the background no i'm
just saying
they call me in high school uh whatever
you're searching i don't constantly have
like twitter open all my emails oh i do
i don't know how are you gonna get the
fresh memes
are you gonna see what happens
i have my phone open constantly
i do the [ __ ] awful thing where i
have twitter open like i scroll i i
scroll up on my twitter i see the
completed timeline close that open my
phone and open up twitter
oh my god [ __ ] damn it
oh my god social media has hacked your
[ __ ] mind yeah i'll open the bbc to
read the news articles i'll close it and
then ten minutes say oh i'll open it
again to see if anything anything else